do not wait until 2024 to start these
Health hacks hey everyone I'm Abby sharp
welcome to aby's
[Music]
Kitchen nears is around the corner and I
know that for a lot of people this means
a lot of Extreme Weight Loss diets that
get abandoned by Valentine's Day as you
guys know I'm not a weight loss Rd but I
do believe in body Aton om and I respect
those who want to lose weight or who
cite weight loss as their nearest
resolution and I would way rather see
people make more gentle evidence-based
healthy Behavior changes than start some
kind of like omad carnivore diet or cut
out all fibers and carbs and I also know
that a lot of folks place weight loss as
their end goal but it's actually not a
good goal because it's not something
that we are 100% in control of our
behaviors on the other hand are
controllable and predictable so so I'm
going to share some super tangible
actionable behaviors hacks and habits
that you can integrate today that
increase your chances of weight loss and
improved overall health now quick note
here that not all of these tips are
going to be good habits for everyone for
some people making one of these swaps
could feel super restrictive be super
triggering result in a rebound or just
not jive with their lifestyle
preferences budget Etc so take what
works for you and leave the rest all of
these are suggestions for gent nutrition
habits to experiment with and of course
don't forget to hit on my description
for my free Hunger crushing combo ebook
and I apologize for the voice my kids
gave me laryngitis again all right let's
get into it tip number one have protein
at every meal and most snacks protein is
King in the satiety hierarchy which is
why it's at the top of my HCC triangle
we know how important maintaining lean
muscle masses for metabolism weight
management and Longevity as we age and
as I discussed in my macros video right
here we also know that focusing on
protein is really important when we're
in a calorie deficit research suggests
that people spontaneously consumed 400
calories less when their protein intake
went from 15 to 30% of calories because
we can only utilize about3 gram of
protein per kilogram of body weight per
meal or snack for muscle protein
synthesis one of the most important
habits that you can get into today is
prioritize protein at every meal ideally
around 20 to 35 gram per sitting adding
protein helps to provide longer lasting
stable satiety energy and blood sugar
levels and increases the chances of
weight loss success without scarcity or
restriction tip two Implement a no
phones at Meal Time rule you guys know I
don't normally like rules but this is
actually one that I can get behind and I
know it's a hard rule to follow because
I literally fail at this 50% of the time
but 50% success rate is like a huge win
to me they've done studies you know 60%
of the time it works every time that
doesn't make sense we know that
distractions like phones tablets and TVs
make listening to our body's hunger and
fullness cues really hard research
suggests that eating while on your phone
increases chloric consumption by about
15% largely because we aren't even
registering emotionally while we ate
we're stripping food of its sensual
satisfaction and also interfering with
the social benefit of a family meal so
no phones at all at the dinner table
they're either off or away charging in
another room where we're not so tempted
by the constant scrolling and
notifications tip three bulk cup and
stretch refined carbs with fiber rich
FEG notice I said bulk cup not cut down
even though the result is usually in
fact cutting down so you know I've got
an additive approach to nutrition which
is why I like to stretch refined carbs
by adding them into a fiber rich veg so
that may mean adding some like zucchini
ribbons to your pasta or adding some
finely diced veg to your rice not only
does this add another layer of flavor
and texture but it turns a low fiber
lower nutrient meal into one that is far
more satiating and even if you don't
change the portion of rice that you put
on your plate at all there's a good
chance you may not need as much of it
because the added fiber from the veggies
adds volume and promotes a TIY which is
important for weight management and this
is a another really key reason why my
Hunger crushing combo Works tip four
choose fats with purpose okay what do I
mean by that well you guys know that our
hunger crushing combo combines protein
which we talked about fiber which we
talked about and healthy fats and I will
never ever suggest that you shouldn't
use oils for cooking or in salad
dressing you should these make naturally
nourishing foods a lot more delicious
but wherever it makes sense I want you
to choose whole food fat sources that
have like dual HCC citizenship so that
have fatten fiber or fat and protein
avocado is a really great example
because it's got 22 G of satiating fats
3 g of protein and has a whopping 10 G
of fiber each making it much more
satiating than an equivalent amount of
fat in oil likewise whole peanuts have
14 G of fats 7.5 g of protein and 2.5 g
of fiber so these Foods offer more
volume flavor and hunger crushing
compounds than straight up oils or fats
so like you could try using avocado as a
sandwich spread or adding nuts or nut
butter as the base for salad dressings
and sauces tip five drink a big glass of
water the moment you get up and another
one as your coffee is brewing I have
discussed this coffee thing ad nauseum
if you want to drink your coffee on an
empty stomach there's likely no real
harm in doing so assuming it doesn't
upset your tummy or cause you raging
anxiety but you've just gone eight or
more hours without any hydration or
nutrition so you want to capitalize on
that morning Thirst by working water
into your coffee ritual the moment you
wake up before you check your phone
drink a full glass of water and as your
coffee is brewing or you're making your
tea or whatever your ritual is drink
another one another one another one this
is really really important for
regularity bloating weight management
energy metabolism cognitive performance
and Joint AB ility tip six use parental
lock functions to limit your phone use
before bed yes I am suggesting that some
of us need to like parent ourselves a
little to limit our phone use before bed
but let me tell you why we know that
screens before bed significantly
interfere with our circadian rhythms and
sleep and poor sleep impacts our
appetite food cravings blood sugars
weight gain cognition and attention
immunity defenses and much more there
are actual like apps for Parental
safeguard s and locks that you can put
into play to lock you out of social
media before after a certain time in the
day and if you're the type to like stay
up late scrolling resulting in really
poor sleep it might be time to use them
Keeping Up with the Kardashians is
nowhere near as important as restorative
sleep and your resulting Health liar tip
seven take one call or virtual meeting
every day while walking exercise doesn't
have to be intentional or sweaty for it
to count in fact you're actually less
likely to compensate by by rewarding
yourself with more food when movement is
framed as fun or leisurely than it is as
exercise so if you have to listen in on
like a boring Zoom conference call turn
the camera off pop your airbuds in and
take it while Meandering around through
like a nearby residential area if you're
waiting on hold with like an airline or
Bank do it in the Great Outdoors yes the
elevator music might kill you inside but
if you do survive you're going to feel
great thanks to the combination of fresh
air and gentle movement this is actually
a bonus step for my adhders but you
actually might find that you can
concentrate much better at what's being
said while simultaneously moving your
body and the best part is this isn't
eating into your busy day tip eight buy
a different fruit and veg than you did
the week before as you guys know I am
big on the importance of variety because
a vary diet is the most likely diet to
meet all of your nutrient needs our gut
bacteria also thrives on diet diversity
but food right now is expensive
especially fresh fruits and veg so most
of us can't afford to eat like three
different fruits and three different
vegetables each day at every meal of the
week so make an intentional point to
switch up which varieties you buy from
week to week if this week it's apples
and broccoli make next week kiwis and
cauliflower if this week you're making
salads with spinach next week Duke kale
Etc this not only helps prevent healthy
eating recipe ruts reducing the risk of
you like throwing in the towel but it's
a foolproof way to ensure greater
nutrient variety over time and speaking
of variety Plan Three mindless
breakfasts to rotate with different
variations unless you're a wellness
influencer no one actually has the
mental energy to come up with a fancy
new breakfast recipe every day of the
week like mornings are hectic enough so
if breakfast takes too much mental
bandwidth you are much more likely to
just like grab a crystal or bacon
sandwich on the go see tip one about the
importance of protein especially in that
morning meal re suggest that having a
protein Rich breakfast significantly
reduces appetite throughout the day and
results in fewer calories consumed at
your next meal so I suggest having three
simple protein Rich breakfast Concepts
that you always have the ingredients for
and you always have like the time and
energy to pull off and then just adding
in slight variations with different
toppings so my three are protein oatmeal
protein smoothie bowl and like a cottage
cheese or yogurt parfait and I switch
things up every week with different
fruits nuts seeds berries cereals and
other crunchy toppings depending on my
mood and on the vibe of breakfast one of
my personal favorite tips is to mix high
sugar cereal with a high fiber whole
grain cereal I do this all the time
because sometimes I just feel like a
little Frosted Flake action but I know
that this isn't going to hold me very
long but I also know that I'm 36 years
old and starting my day with like a bowl
of sugar doesn't feel super great for me
or for my gut so rather than putting
sugary cereal up on a pedestal and
telling myself I can never have it again
which we all know gives our friend Tony
way too much
power I added to a bowl of high fiber
cereal like brand flakes or my morning
oats oh I love a little Lucky Charms
moment on proin notes trust me if you a
sugary cereal lover this hack will
change your life tip 11 experiment with
fruit as a sweetener I'm never going to
tell you not to put honey in your
oatmeal or to like make cookies without
sugar but don't underestimate the
natural sweetness of fruit ripe mashed
banana is amazing in oatmeal yogurt
baked goods Etc and freeze dried berries
either like ground up or whole also adds
a ton of flavor antioxidants and natural
sweetness again this is all about an
additive approach to nutrition so by
adding a ripe banana to your oatmeal we
not only are cutting back on the need
for a lot of brown sugar but we add
volume and add a ton of sating nutrition
that keeps us Fuller longer tip 12 drink
two sips of water in between every sip
of alcohol I could and should do a whole
video on alcohol The Good the Bad and
the Ugly but again I will never tell you
not to have an occasional drink if
that's what brings you Joy like I will
never tell myself that but drinking too
too much too fast is not only damaging
to our long-term Health but has
immediate unpleasant consequences
alcohol affects quality sleep which we
already established is Bad News Bears it
causes constipation bloating dehydration
puffiness and other hangover
symptoms we up it also lowers
inhibitions which increases the
likelihood of overeating and of course
it adds excess calories without
providing much useful nutrition so we do
see an increased risk of obesity in
heavy drinkers so the new guidelines
actually suggest limiting alcohol to two
drinks per week and if you drink more
than that to limit to no more than two
drinks per sitting to accomplish that
and also to prevent the dreaded hangover
I suggest trying to take a minimum of
two big sips of water between each sip
of alcohol this will slow you down
prevent overc consumption and keep you
hydrated to mitigate some of the
aftermath effects effects tip 13 when
dining out if you can start with a
vegetable based appetizer or Salad yes
there's a lot of diet websites that will
insist you like fill up on a plain salad
or broth-based soup before you eat your
Mane to reduce your calorie consumption
when dining out and honestly that
suggestion is actually evidence-based so
research has found that starting a meal
with a salad reduces the meal's caloric
intake by 12% but this is not the reason
why I make this suggestion I make this
suggestion to a encourage more fiber
intake which is generally lacking in
restaurant food and can be super
important to counteract the digestion
slowing effects of a lot of excess
sugars fat and alcohol and B prevent
yourself from falling into an all or
nothing mentality when dining out folks
who have heavily restricted calories for
most of their life tend to get into like
a Last Supper mentality when they get
off their diet in a restaurant where
they feel the need need to get like the
fried appetizer and the creamy cheesy
pasta and the bread and the cheesecake
and the bottle of wine because diet
starts tomorrow folks YOLO but by
starting with something nutritious like
a salad you're automatically kicked out
of that All or Nothing trap and you can
make more balanced choices that actually
feel good to your body and still satisfy
those Cravings tip 14 batch prep meal
building blocks not completed recipes
meal prep can be super helpful when
you're trying to Kickstart more healthy
diet habits but one of the biggest
reasons why people don't stick to it is
that they get bloody bored of eating the
same meal pre lunch all week long I feel
that if you're not excited about your
meal you're more likely to accidentally
leave it at home and buy something on
the go so I suggest making big batches
of meal components that can be
reassembled into a variety of different
meals throughout the week so grill a
bunch of chicken breast or tofu cook a
big pot of quinoa or rice pan roast a
couple types of different veg and from
there you can do salads sandwiches soups
stir fries bowls tacos and more tip 15
put pre- prepped fruits and veggies in
clear glass containers our food choices
often come down to marketing and
convenience so we kind of have to be
good marketers for nutritious Foods one
of my favorite ways to do this is by
spending about 30 minutes on a Sunday
when I get the groceries home to wash
and prep all the produce I put
everything into clear containers so that
I can visually see what's in them and
then I pop them into the fridge at eye
level not hidden behind the milk or the
leftovers it's got to be front and
center so when you get home from a long
day and you're ravenous and you will eat
whatever is convenient those pre-
chopped fruits and veggies will be like
staring at you as the most intuitive
Easy Choice and finally a little bonus
tip here because I could not not share
this whenever you reheat your Le
leftovers whether they're homemade or
they're from like a restaurant throw a
handful or two of spinach or leafy
greens with a pinch of salt into the
bottom of the bowl as your meal reheats
it will Wilt the greens and marinate
them in whatever kind of like sauce or
seasoning your leftovers contain adding
more volume fiber and nutrients without
any kind of additional effort well folks
that's all that I have for you guys
today I really hope that these
actionable gentle nutrition habits can
replace more like lofty abstract weight
schools as we go into a new New Year's
resolution season but I really hope you
like this please give us a thumbs up
leave me a comment below if you have any
actionable healthy eating habits that
have really done wonders for you don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
check out my Hunger crushing combo ebook
in the description and I'll see you next
time on aby's kitchen
[Music]
bye